françaises français il y à 7 ans j'avais
un rêve après demain je quitterais
l'elysée je viens ce soir vous dire très
simplement aurevoir
je vous demande de vous souvenir de ceux
ci la france est restée le pays de
toutes les libertés
pour son bien et pour sa grotte vous
m'entendez valérie il faut partir
maintenant
des zooms jp des zooms tout doux tout
doux votre texte valérie voilà on est
d'accord il va sortir par la porte de
droite c'est prévu attention top
marseillais droite à droite à droite
havre à droite valérie fait tout pour le
parti trammell jpl panalpina tombe en
train de le faire cet enseignant l'a
perdu
eh bien vous retrouver je pense mais
quand je vais le retrouver sur la troupe
en aqua sur la deux le président serait
sortie de l'elysée non moi j'ai rien sur
le perron les gars 1 lalala sur l'a7
qu'est ce qu'ils font en sorte il adore
le foot il a d'ailleurs admis que c'est
dans ce jeu de tête sa vers lomé c'est
en fait ce qui était le cas elle
l'attend on leur père ou leur père il
est où vivent les français s'inquiètent
ils se baladent nos vacances la pulpe et
on a vu plus tôt il a dû voir cloud et
la torre toujours sur mon m'a dit 'il va
sortir par la porte de droite j'attends
qu'ils reviennent qu'il sorte par la
porte de droite et puis c'est tout il
reviendra plus il est parti
tous
[Musique]
oh
à
ah ah
mais je n'avais pas vu que la porte soit
elle très loin